et la fois seulement qu'il se calme
qu'est ce qui s'est passé quand même
insisté raciste y'a pas de problème on
continue de [ __ ] insultes racistes
lancés de bananes cris de singe on
pensait que c'est désolant spectacle qui
ont cours en europe ne traversera jamais
l'océan et pourtant m'insulter de ça je
me dis nous claque mon cou et
c'était vraiment c'était vraiment
vraiment désagréable le 14 octobre
dernier lors d'un match éliminatoire de
la coupe de la première ligue de soccer
du québec
le joueur du cs longueuil davy makoun ça
est victime d'insultés racistes
le défenseur de 25 ans qui a évolué en
europe ne pensais jamais voir cela ici
en venant au canada je sais que le
canada ils ont la mentalité elle est
vraiment différente des français c'est
un pays vraiment avec des gens très
agréables des gens calmes et que ça
m'arrive ici ça m'a choqué je vais pas
vous mentir
le joueur coupable a finalement été
suspendu 15 matchs l'entraîneur du cs
longueuil anthony rimasson qui
entraînait de nombreuses années en
france a constaté que ces actes sont
loin d'être isolé à chaque fois que mes
entraîneurs donné des consignes on
entend des quelques joueurs faire des
bruits des bruits d'animaux et des
bruits de singe donc déclaré à l'arbitré
puis les arbitres ferment les yeux parce
qu'on banalise la chose nous sommes
allés rencontrer le commissaire de la
première ligue de soccer du québec lors
de la finale de la coupe kambiz ebadi a
été surpris lorsqu'on lui ai dit que ces
problèmes de racisme sont endémiques
dans sa ligue
vous me surprenez parce que si ces
propos là été échangé que les joueurs
avaient six avaient fait une plainte aux
usa ventes à notre attention
il y aurait sûrement pris aussi des
décisions comment on a pris une décision
très dure envers cette jour qui a changé
les paroles qui 15 matches cette crise
est arrivée
angelo jean baptiste a joué et entraîné
dans plus d'une trentaine de pays dans
le monde
il ne pensait pas lui non plus être
confrontées à de tels actes ici elle
joue venezuela on m'appelait negrito
menegatto c'était pas du tout méchant
c'était plutôt affectueux la façon que
les gens le faisais mais ici quand on
vous traite de sale [ __ ] il y a un nom
angelo jean baptiste a voulu protester
auprès du commissaire de la ligue contre
des propos racistes dont avait été
victime l'un de ses joueurs
moi j'avais demandé à mes ses ébats dit
il faut trouver un moyen de faire après
vingt chambres qu'il s'est joint des
choses à ne se répète pas à moi
on m'a menacé non il ne faut pas faire
ça il ne faut pas dénoncent ces choses
là voici la réponse de cambyse ebadi
prenez note que tout autre écart de
conduite de la sorte de la part de
monsieur jean baptiste sera aussitôt
soumis au comité de discipline
provincial des vies lui a décidé de
s'exprimer ouvertement pour crever
l'abcès pour que les gestes humiliant
qui perdure en europe ne s'installe pas
ici je pense qu'on devrait déjà
sanctionné faire de la prévention et
qu'on essaie de d'arrêter cette haine si
robert frosi radio canada montréal